good to see you thank you absolutely all
right come on the Paris agreement ended
up being a historic agreement not
because it gets us to where we need to
be eventually but for the first time
locking in all countries into verifiable
steps and targets that they're gonna
take it creates the architecture that
allows us to finally start dealing with
this problem in a serious way so you
were happy with I was happy that we put
the architecture in place big the
targets that have been set in Paris are
nowhere near enough for what the
scientists tell us we have to do
eventually to solve this problem but if
we can use the next 20 years to apply
existing technologies to reduce carbon
emissions and then start slowly turning
up the dials as new technologies come
online so that we have more and more
ambitious targets each year then we're
not going to completely reverse the
warming that now is inevitable but we
can stop it before it becomes
catastrophic it's no secret that you've
been under great opposition to try to
implement some of your climate change
initiatives and we've got some folks on
this so somebody that comes into office
it does not believe in the science of
climate change right do they have the
capacity and the power to dismantle
everything that you've already worked
for even if somebody came in campaigning
on denying climate science reality has a
way of yeah hidden in the nose if you're
if you're not paying attention and I
think that the public is starting to
realize the science in part because it's
indisputable I admire your optimism yeah
but you start to look at the science
look at what's going on in the Antarctic
uns and scientists saying that there are
sections of ice that guarantee four to
six meters of ocean level rise which
will be catastrophic for the future you
are the leader of the free world you
have access to information that most
people do not what makes you terrified
for the future a huge portion of the
world's population
lives near oceans mm-hmm if they start
moving then you start seeing scarce
resources the subject to competition
between populations this is the reason
why the Pentagon has said this is a
national security issue this isn't just
an environmental issue there's a
national security issue you know in
addition to just the sadness that I
would feel if my kids can never see a
glacier the way I saw when I went up to
Alaska yeah that's the romantic side of
me that's the side that takes a walk
with my daughters and I want to be able
to them to see or my grandkids I want
them to see the same things I saw as I
was growing up even if you were
unsentimental about that in very
hard-headed terms you've got to worry
about the national security implications
of this and the capacity for the
existing world order as we understand it
to survive the kinds of strains that the
scientists are predicting with that
action this is why we have to take
action now